[Music]
as part of the netflix event to them
last weekend there was news about the
long-running hit stranger things the
franchise which is about to enter its
fourth season surprised fans with a new
video clip which is quite impressive you
can see a seemingly normal house in
which a family of the 1950s moves in
however the so-called creel house hardly
grants the new residents one peaceful
moment
you don't need to be ghost hunter to
notice that something isn't right there
next we see scenes that could have been
taken from a conjuring part as the
father seems to have done something
terrible following a cut we see the same
house only a few years later in the
meantime it has become an eerie rune and
we can see some familiar characters from
the series taking a closer look at the
interior of the property finally we see
an ominous looking grandfather clock and
an increasingly gloomy environment that
is strongly reminiscent of the shadow
world of stranger things although there
is nothing more to be seen in the short
clip we assume that the house will play
a crucial role in the upcoming fourth
season a more detailed plot is sadly not
yet known either but we do expect david
harbor to return his upper after he was
more or less considered gone at the end
of the last season until next year we
will have to remain patient as a more
precise date has not yet been set for
the fourth season which will comprise a
total of nine episodes
there are very few playstation titles
that enjoy such a good reputation as the
last of us series the game from the
talented developer team naughty dog
tells a gripping and above all emotional
story about the ill-matched survivor
couple joel and ellie jill's a grumpy
often very calculating contemporary with
a good heart while ellie is still a
clueless naive girl at the beginning of
the story together they experience all
kinds of adventures in a
post-apocalyptic world and have to stand
their ground not only against human
scavengers but above all against fungus
mutated undead now a picture of the two
main characters has appeared which only
depicts them from behind but which has
already caused a lot of excitement due
to the extremely high popularity of the
two video games at first glance this
could also be a shot taken straight from
the game but in fact we do see the two
actors pedro pascal and balor ramsay
pascal is of course well known as the
main actor of the also very popular
series the mandalorian ramsay on the
other hand may be familiar to many from
the last season of game of thrones
series in which pascal also made an
impressive appearance
the last of us is being produced under
the hbo name while naughty doc is
actively supporting the production after
all the fans do not want to be upset
with an ordinary copy naturally techno
is based on the two previously released
games but the producers also want to
deliberately add new elements meanwhile
shooting of the first season of the last
of us is still in full swing which means
that the series might not be released
before the end of 2022 if not before
2023
netflix has been bringing the witcher
franchise to the screens of the world
with its own series for nearly two years
now the universe which is largely based
on the book series by anza j sabovsky is
without a doubt one of the streaming
giant's long-running hits and now the
series is finally set to officially get
a third season
after the start of season 2 is being
postponed by a year to do the pandemic
this is some good news at last two
freshly released clips of this season
are also pleasing the fans as not only
do we get to see christopher u.s nibilan
but also a geralt's infamous mentor
visimir for the first time he is
embodied by kim bonney who joins the
cast around henry cavill as geralt anja
kalotra as jennifer and freya allen as
siri in addition the cast will include
cassie clear as felipe eilhardt and
eduardo as mother naneke liz carr plays
jacob femme graham mctavish takes on the
role of sigismund dixtra and chris
fulton embodies the evil matrions so
both fans of the books and fans of the
at least equally popular game series
should have plenty to look forward to
with many old familiar characters henry
cavill recently revealed in an interview
with entertainment weekly that he was
particularly excited about his
character's interaction with vasamir
some highlights of the upcoming season
are said to lie in geralt's relationship
with his mentor anyway and of course
with his foster daughter siri there's
even more news from the witcher in
addition to the already released spin of
nightmare of the wolf netflix is also
planning his second animated film which
like the regular season 3 is still
without a release date as if that
weren't enough fans can also look
forward to his spin-off called the
witcher blood origin as you can see
netflix is not getting tired of
constantly producing new content for the
very profitable franchise but for now
fans can look forward to season 2 which
will be released on december 17th 2021
the upcoming aquaman and the lost
kingdom is taking shape the main cast
around jason momoa as aquaman and amber
heard as mera was already known
abdulmedin ii joins as black manta
patrick wilson plays orm and dolph
lundgren embodies king nerius fans can
now look forward to further first class
additions as was recently announced
netflix star indian mover will take on
the role of the antagonistic character
karshan also known as the shark this one
may be familiar to some from the green
lantern comics where she not only
possesses telepathic powers but can also
emit radioactive emissions in addition
flash of the titans actor vincent regan
slips into the role of king atlan who
was once the ruler of atlantis and
already appeared in the first part by
means of flashbacks albeit with a
different cast at that time the last
newcomer confirmed is johnny zhao she
hasn't really had the chance to gain
experience on the big screen yet but is
now expected to play the character
stingray and what makes it so special is
that stingray is actually not from the
comics and embodies a role created
solely for this sequel last but not
least we are happy to see a returning
character from the first part that has
not been previously announced it's
randall park whom we already know from
the mid-credits scene in the prequel he
plays marine biologist steven shim who
has made a pact with black manta the
deal involves manda taking him to
atlantis in exchange for helping him
defeat aquaman you can find out the
outcome at the end of next year on
december 16 2022
last weekend an animated film about
super mario bros was announced with
great media impact and it is already in
production
this is not a bad move after all the
bouncing italian plumber is one of the
best known video game characters around
and just about everyone has warped
through pipes and hurt turtle shells at
enemies after the unsuccessful
live-action adaption super mario
brothers from 1993 a new screen
appearance is badly needed because what
was seen back then elicits either broad
laughter or dismissive hat shaking today
so it's all the better that first it's
an animated movie and second that the
voice actors are as popular and talented
as mario himself marvel star chris pratt
takes on the lead role while other roles
will feature anya tell a choice princess
peach charlie day is mario's brother
luigi and jack black as bowser toad will
be voiced by keegan michael key seth
rogen will appear as donkey kong and
fred armistead's donkey kong's grandbug
cranky kong kevin michael richardson
sebastian manoscallo also appear in
supporting roles as bowser's companions
of course this brings up the question of
the film's plot for this we will have to
be patient for a little longer however
speculation that peach will be kidnapped
by bowser and mario and his friends will
have to rescue her once again is
probably not a bit of a stretch
according to super mario creator shigeru
miyamoto work on the film is already
well underway and has been running
smoothly so far the same studio that is
also responsible for the success of the
minions is in charge of the ideal
implementation so besides the
outstanding cast you can look forward to
some first-class animated action super
mario bros the movie is scheduled for
release in the united states on december
21 2022
the end of extraction raised a few
questions among viewers no surprise then
that a first teaser for the sequel
extraction 2 has now been released the
action thriller created by the russo
brothers has been the number one most
watched netflix original movie for ages
even well ahead of bird box 6
underground and army of the dead
therefore a follow-up is not unexpected
and filming is expected to start this
fall in addition to director sam
hargrave lead actor chris hemsworth is
also returning as you can easily see on
instagram the 38 year old is already
working out to get fit for his role as a
mercenary the main character tyler rick
is not really a couch potato after all
currently there is no date for the
sequel so for the time being we will
have to settle for the coming soon shown
in the trailer
so that were the current news about the
world of series and films if you want to
keep up to date with the latest news
feel free to subscribe to our channel
and click on the notification bell you
can also find a great new movie clip
from venom let there be carnage on our
channel so make sure to check it out
[Music]